el mes del ayuno la oración y la
reflexión en comunidad para el islam
culmina contenciones políticas en varios
países musulmanes
Durante este ramadán la violencia llegó
hasta el interior de la mezquita de
alacsa en Jerusalén el tercer lugar más
sagrado para los seguidores de Mahoma la
policía israelí atacó a decenas de
fieles y arrestó a centenares otros en
medio de una redada antiterrorista según
autoridades de Israel tras una escalada
de las tensiones con los territorios
palestinos hoy en medio de la
celebraciones del atem portavoz de jamás
grupo islamista que controla la franja
de gaza recuerda las tensiones entre
musulmanes y judíos
se celebra este año después de una
batalla librada por nuestro pueblo
palestino tras la agresión contra la
mezquita de alaxa y una guerra religiosa
total
a más de 3000 kilómetros en la capital
de Afganistán la deplorable situación de
derechos de las mujeres y la crisis
humanitaria tras la retoma talibán en
agosto de 2021 afecta a los festejos de
Late
es muy diferente a los anteriores antes
nuestros amigos estaban aquí íbamos a
sus casas y lucíamos nuestra ropa éramos
tan felices pero ahora ellos se fueron
del país y nosotras no podemos ir a
ningún lado
mientras que en África los combates
entre el ejército sudanés y el grupo
paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo rápido No
cesan en las calles de jartum ignorando
los múltiples llamados a tregua por la
celebración de Late
llega este año mientras nuestro país se
desangra con muertos y heridos saludo a
los soldados de mi país ustedes se
sacrifican por esta querida patria
Según la OMS el ramadán cierra con más
de 400 muertos en Sudán